[Music]
all right
yep how's everything going can everybody
hear
us okay yeah hopefully we just recorded
some [ __ ] so hopefully
the microphone is not doing its weird
thing
yeah we recorded the uh review of uh
young frankenstein yeah came out good
which is gonna
be up at the end of the week for you
guys
but yeah so um esther said hi jenny tom
bob is getting me all three volumes of
faceless villain for my birthday
yeah she sent me a message on patreon
and said that yet and said that that was
uh thank you very much because her
birthday is at the beginning of june are
you
i told her like happy early birthday
yeah yeah i hope you like them tell me
i think i mean i think they came out
good but i do say so myself
everybody likes them they seem to
i still got to get back on that fourth
one like i said i got two chapters of it
written but i just
got so distracted by other things that i
haven't been able to work on it
but i'll eventually uh get around to it
yeah
yeah so uh so yesterday we saw
i the tiger the third one the third one
like i said we were gonna do all three
of them on one show but then we saw the
first two and then we didn't have time
to watch the third one so we weren't
getting
them last night yeah i think i fell
asleep during the second one a little
bit too
yeah i might have dozed off a little bit
during this one as well but
i think badger called it the other day
this is the weakest one out of the three
it's not a bad movie but it doesn't beat
the golden voyage of sinbad that's the
best one
the thing about this one i think this
one was the first one that i saw because
i'm pretty sure that i saw it
either to drive in or to regular theater
so i probably saw it like
when it first came out like in 1977 so i
would have been about five or six years
old
and i you know what i distinctly
remember
wanting to go see it and being
disappointed that there wasn't more
tiger in it i was hoping that there
would be a tiger like through the whole
thing because i was like tigers
rad you know what i mean yeah um but
really there's kind of like a
saber-tooth tiger a smilodon or
something like at the end
and it's not a tiger yeah it's not
really a tiger you're thinking of a
tiger it's got stripes on it
the whole time that's not what it is
it's more like a
it's more like a just like a lion a lot
like it's like a lioness with [ __ ]
saber with the
big old it's a smilodon that's right
let's go okay
but uh doesn't really matter that's just
a
it's just a small part of the movie i
think the whole eye of the tiger
um uh angle is the sorceress's eyes
when she does certain yeah cat eyes pop
out
which uh not really explained but it
doesn't have to be explained yeah she's
like a witch you know
i would say the i would say that this is
the weakest out of the three it's like i
said it's not bad it just has certain
problems
um the the dialogue is kind of muddy
there's no reason to have certain
dialogue especially in like the first
one sixth maybe one quarter of the movie
a bunch of dialogue happens that isn't
real clear
you know it's like it's like you don't
really know what the movie is about
then finally it starts to settle down
they have to go to this damn island
to get a prince
uh converted back into a human being he
got turned into a baboon
as one does yeah you got to go to this
island to get this wise man and then
once you find the wise man you got to go
go to another place to get the
transformation done and he's um
he's the heir to the throne uh to become
a sultan
and you got to get him on the throne
because his mom has another son from
or you know this is a son from two
different mothers okay yeah this is
uh zenobia is the stepmom the evil
stepmother stepmom
she's a sorcerer she's trying to get her
son on the throne
so uh there's kind of a cool element you
know what i mean because she shows up
when you first see her the
the the sultan is like oh [ __ ] here's my
wife yeah
be quiet don't say nothing around her
she shows up with her own entourage it's
like
she's a villain when she appears and
she's just this english chick with a
russian accent and she just
she's as russian as hell through the
whole thing uh kind of an ice queen
and um they make a damn mechanical
minotaur called mennoton and everything
is i remembered it as a kid you know
it was pretty cool you know they make us
a heart and everything she brings him
alive with the spell
um it gets kind of disappointing though
towards the end you know what i mean
[ __ ] minotaur goes out like a [ __ ]
he does a little bit yeah you're like
you built that thing and all it did was
row the boat and pull the [ __ ] stone
out of the bed
and then it died well you assumed that
it got crushed
i think it was supposed to fight the
trog at the end like the troglodyte i
think it was supposed to fight him at
the end like that was one of the
first things that they were throwing
around yeah it must have been uh
like uh budgetary constraints that fight
never happened
okay so the weird thing about this i dug
a little bit into the
kind of the history behind this trilogy
so like i said the first one came out in
1958 and then when
golden voyage of sinbad came out in 1973
it was like really really successful
you know it made a [ __ ] ton of money so
um so then columbia pictures immediately
like i think while the second one was
still in theaters
they started saying okay well we need to
make a third one so they
were throwing around a bunch of ideas
for it now see i had the tiger i don't
think was the original title it was
supposed to be called something like
sinbad at the world's end or something
like that because they wanted this to be
the biggest budgeted one and they wanted
it to be
like a more globe trotting one which it
is i mean he does
go you know out to this like greek
island and then he goes like to the
antarctic or
you know antarctica or whatever or
wherever that is or the arctic circle
so they did do that um another thing too
is that they wanted to
focus i guess ray harryhausen you know
obviously he was kind of behind
uh the writing of this as well i think
the script was also co-written by the
woman that did um
uh jason the argonauts as well but
he wanted the the monsters to be less
fantasy based and more
like prehistoric animals um
and i think because i think somebody
mentioned earlier like the big giant
walrus that they have to fight at one
point i think that was originally
supposed to be a yeti
okay but then for whatever reason they
decided to do a walrus instead
giant walrus couldn't be a regular
walrus it had to be a giant one
well just a regular wallace because the
wall was coming towards you it'd be like
right it's a walrus you know yeah that
you're bigger than them kind of
i mean well it depends on what kind of
walrus it is i guess you're pretty
[ __ ] big yeah that's true
but yeah so the story behind this one
now i think that john philip law who
played sinbad and the second one
was actually supposed to be in this one
too but i guess by the time they got
around to making it like he couldn't do
it for whatever reason
so they got um patrick wayne
who fun fact is john wayne's son and uh
actually started out i think when he was
younger like acting in some movies with
his dad
he uh looks like the lost bg in this one
though i gotta say like some of the
shirts
especially that uh the last scene when
they go to the shrine
and that shirt that he has on and he
just god he looks so much
he looks so much like a bg it's like
every time he was like in that scene i
kept going ah
ah ah yeah staying live
i know and he's just like stopping
you're taking that look
that was a cool look for that era though
that was a very cool look for that era
era you know what i mean that bg's
back then it makes me wonder if i have
the tiger might mod was that a reference
to the survivor song
no they came later no this came out like
way before the survivor
yeah it got kind of confused about what
era
was and every time i think of that
survivor song i think of the weird al
yankovic parody of it
which is like about going to a deli or
the cousin
having having seen this movie
made me makes me think that when i saw
it in the theater
it was a double feature that played
golden voyages in bed and this one
because some of this stuff some of the
stuff from golden voyage i thought was
in this movie
yeah you know what i mean but no but i
remembered everything that i'd
everything that this movie showed me i
remembered it here's here's another
problem with it
certain shots look great uh
other scenes where there's a lot of
special effects happen and it gets
really really grainy it's because
they're using
layered stuff superimposer along with
mats
and then [ __ ] a lot of it was
miniatures miniatures and then
yeah and it it it doesn't look as
handcrafted or as well detailed
as as uh as golden voyage golden voyage
feels a lot more expensive even though
this one was the most expensive one yeah
you can't really tell but
well yeah the thing about it it's like
the stop-motion animation looks amazing
like always like that you know the
smiling on
the troglodyte that looks amazing the
baboon looks amazing because that's also
stop motion
but the traveling mat shots um
those pretty much universally look like
crap and they don't even look as good as
the ones from 1958 yeah like because
there's one point in this where the
witch
turns herself into a seagull which
doesn't look that good and then she
comes back and she's miniature
and she's running around like in the you
know in the little ship
but i think that the miniature lady from
the 1958 one looked better than the one
in the 1977 one
yeah that's the effects from that when
when she was shrunk down yeah
maybe well because what ended up
happening with this
was that a lot of the [ __ ] like the
stuff they filmed like in petra
and you know in jordan which like i said
they also used in one of the indiana
jones movies
last crusade i think it was um that was
shot later
so when you see a shot there's one shot
with like the whole cast or whatever the
entourage like standing in front of the
thing like in petra
those are all stand-ins um so anytime
you see the actual cast
um and petra is in the background that's
all
matt because none of them went there
yeah you know what i'm saying
so a lot of the stuff and a lot um i
think all the scenes most of the scenes
with uh some of the tombs and stuff not
the tomb but like the shrine kind of
thing it's like i think
that was almost all miniature so they
had to be like matted into that
yeah and it just doesn't really it
doesn't look that good yeah you can tell
they're not on location
yeah just kind of cheapens it i think
you could probably fix it with modern
computer technology it needs to be
remastered
there's probably a bunch of stuff you
could do to you probably should
i think better it's just that it's
the special effects i think they're kind
of
they what's the tone
the the tone that you get from seeing
these special effects
is not as charming as as as golden as
as the uh as the first two as the first
two yeah
it just doesn't feel as good it feels
like it feels like an uneven tone you
get realism
and then something that looks like
fantasy and kind of fake and then it
goes back to kind of realism like a
clear
shot it looks really good and then it
gets crappy again it's a very uneven
tone
and it's kind of throwing you out of it
and i didn't remember that
as a kid seeing it of course on the big
screen maybe the copies were fresher and
it looked better back then
or maybe because i was just a kid yeah
um but i
i remember the movie being popular
people talking about it
yeah it did kind of make a lot of money
although like i said i think nowadays in
retrospect i think most people will
agree that it's the weakest and i think
even ray harryhausen later
even though his stop-motion looks really
good in this like it like it always did
um i think that he said well it seemed
kind of rushed
um and like i said they didn't really
like
i mean when they got patrick wayne for
the uh for the lead because john phillip
law couldn't do it
um you know they said he didn't really
have a lot of charisma him and jane
seymour didn't really have any uh
chemistry
uh together i could notice that and um
you know so that was something so they
had like a lot of problems like when
they were making it like i said the
production of it was very rushed they
were trying to get it out as quickly as
possible even though it still took like
four years to make it but i mean
jane seymour she's cute but she's now
caroline monroe
was a lot cuter you know and of course
you know they were showing her off a lot
i mean he's
she's just she's just a kind of generic
if you ask me and then they have another
girl that shows up later
who's got to like kind of like to stand
in for [ __ ]
archimedes he's supposed to be
archimedes friends kind of a greek
scientist
and his psychic daughter is there and
she didn't really have a whole lot of
chemistry either
just like somebody they shoehorned in
there you know
yeah that was tyrone power's daughter
taylor power i think she was in a couple
of movies but she didn't really want to
be an actor
so i don't think she was in much
happiness the only
woman in this that kind of had any kind
of charisma
is the evil witch she was up
and did a good job in a hot old witchy
lady
she wasn't that old she's probably 40.
her eyeshadow game was on point
yeah she was in good shape and uh you
know
she's uh she had that [ __ ] badass
kind of black
cloak and uh doing [ __ ] spells and
she was just more she was just you know
an interesting character
yeah you know and they wasted a lot with
with her and this minotaur
there really should have been a lot more
of that man see that's what i see
okay so i kind of thought here's okay
one thing let me point this out before i
forget about it i thought i was going
crazy but
the guy that plays the witch's
uh zenobia's son who she's trying to get
on the throne
which is why she turns the actual prince
into a baboon like you do
that guy i'm like that guy looks like
one of the guys that was on sinbad's
crew
in golden voyage of sinbad and i'm like
maybe it's just maybe he just looks like
him no that's the same dude okay
they just he's playing a different
character but i was kind of like that
seemed like a weird choice to make but
anyway
yeah uh but yeah so so her whole plot is
like i said she wants her son
she's the stepmom she wants her son to
be on the throne so she turns kasim who
is
you know the next in succession into a
baboon
and so that kind of sends them off to
like find somebody that can fix the
spell or whatever
so her and her son build this big
brass minotaur called minneton like you
said
and it's really cool it's like this
really cool sequence and they make like
this
kind of cool like clockworky sort of
heart thing
and it's just like it's gonna do her
bidding right but then i kind of feel
like
they should have done more with that
because he looked so cool and
pretty much all he did was when they
were you know following the
sinbad and the crew like out to find uh
melanthius or whatever that dude's name
was
and then going on so so he all he did
was like steer the boat
and [ __ ] like that oh you know when they
did the um when they did like close-ups
of minotaur it was stop motion obviously
but when they did long shots there was a
person in that and do you know who was
in that
uh peter mayhew the guy that played
chewbacca oh okay that was that was his
first uh i think his first uh film role
okay
he was like i don't know if he was
credited but yeah he was like the live
uh the live actor inside the miniton
costume when they showed it from far
away yeah well there was a whole hell of
a lot of build up for the minotaur
and it looked really cool and it did
cool [ __ ] it could row a boat for six
men
they got into the witch's ship and it
didn't even have sails
you just had minneton back there go and
row in this thing like this and it would
row
[ __ ] six of the oars down there so he
was kind of like the he was
he was a motorboat yeah
[Laughter]
yeah he was a boat motor and then they
get to where they're going finally
he does kill a few guys they're in the
water
oh no that's right he's he speared a
couple yeah he killed a couple guys
and then there's a lot of build up you
know they even showed his construction
and she has this you know minotaur will
be our army and she spends the whole
[ __ ] movie yelling at it
i know that this is expecting the
minotaur to turn around like smacking
her one
although i could call you that if you
want me to so a little minotaur
yeah and then you know they get where
they're going and a minute's on
open this make an opening and then the
thing [ __ ] pulls the block out and
crushes itself
she looks down and goes he's done his
job
[Laughter]
not really not really because she had
built this up to where
this was going to be your army and your
you still got you still got
a [ __ ] sinbad most most of his crew
and then you got the damn troglodyte
monster with them you know
there was a lot of [ __ ] he could have
done yeah i kind of
thought that that was going to be one of
he was going to be like in the main like
boss fight
yeah like i thought it was going to be
like
versus everybody and this milodon versus
everybody in the crew versus minotaur
yeah see it should have just been a
you know big brouhaha yeah her son gets
killed he falls down the stairs
and he ain't that something i don't
break down breaks his neck
come on man i thought that's supposed to
be an english movie i mean you know they
can usually come up with some better
[ __ ] than that
the minotaur crushed himself and then
the boy falls down the stairs and breaks
his own damn neck
all right and then like they both went
out like [ __ ]
and then evil sorceress she does she she
does the last thing she could do which
is
she astrally projects out of her body
and jumps into an old frozen
saber-toothed tiger that looks like a
fluffy
herb it is pretty cute yeah it looks
like a fluffy fur animal
kind of like something a teenage girl
put on her bed
that's what it looks like and then she
that thing comes down
kills the damn troglodyte i know strong
with the nice
guy yeah charlotte is fighting and
finding it and [ __ ]
and the brave you know kona
sinbad and his brave crew stand there i
know they're
like backing up maybe we should leave
yeah they watch it
it's it's fighting to defend them and
it's you know what i mean and they're
not even helping out i'm like you want
to get jump in there and like help trog
that yeah
they finally decided to [ __ ] jump in
there and help out
after it's killed yeah pretty much
already sitting there dying
okay let's help him out well yeah thanks
[ __ ]
you know i know drugs like you humans
yeah he fighting to defend you you let
him [ __ ] you let you let him [ __ ]
get shoot up
things tearing his back up biting him on
the neck
yeah it was kind of sad oh so trogg was
really kind of the hero of the movie
yeah
honestly it just just felt like it
didn't quite have the scope
of the second one if even though it went
to more locations
they seem to not carry the same weight i
think you know what and i think
too this would have benefited um from a
from being a bit shorter
because i do kind of feel like a lot of
time was spent
on the chase you know what i mean them
like being on the ship
and like having zenobia chasing after
them like with minotaur in the boat and
everything kind of a weekend
and it just yeah and it just seemed like
that went on too long it was just kind
of like hey here's them
on the boat talking about where they're
going and then here's the witch and her
son and minneton on this boat like
following after them
and they had all these locations some of
them fictional locations you know
it was like some of them were not actual
locations they were miniatures some of
them
and then they were superimposed into
real locations because they weren't
there
that was that looked weird too remember
they're walking down that valley
yeah and that's a real valley but you
could tell they're not there you could
clearly see their
superimposed it just it just yeah it
felt cheap like i said a lot of the
stuff
they you know the the second unit crew
went and
went to the locations and filmed the
locations and then later on they had all
the actors or prior to that they had the
actors just doing [ __ ] in a studio or
whatever
not as bad as say land of the lost but
you know what i mean
same concept yeah of what they're doing
there
um but yeah they had all these locations
that they're putting them in but
nothing's really happening in the
locations that's really
it didn't it didn't it didn't feel it
didn't feel very important
the golden voyage of sinbad was very
different
it was kind of more epic it felt a lot
more epic and it felt a lot more well
put together
it was all a consistent tone throughout
the entire movie in terms of
the way the uh the way the uh the film
quality looked and the way things were
shot
you see the more [ __ ] they layer on
there the more resolution they're losing
so you [ __ ] did it didn't really look
good
you know they have a real nice tight
shot with real bright colors
and then they'd switch over to another
camera angle and it looked real grainy
and
it's kind of muddy together and yeah and
you just like yeah
you said i think it could probably be
fixed with modern technology
but i guess the movie really isn't
considered to be
you know so important to where somebody
spend money money and time to go in
there and fix that
well i don't know i just feel like um i
think i've seen a couple of british
reviewers talking about this and they
had like a three
volume set like so they all came like in
a big blu-ray set yeah so i don't know
if it's been
remastered since then right because you
have to think that
i mean just a couple years after this
like clash of the titans came
out and clash of the titans looks really
good i mean there's a couple of like
ropey looking uh matte shots in that too
but
i don't know like i said that was the
thing that bothered me like i said the
stop motion animation looks good like
all the monsters and i especially want
to give a shout
out to like the little demons or ghouls
or whatever like near the beginning
because those look yeah
yeah um oh and i will say too that tr
that trogg
um i think that they used the same
armature later to make calabas
in uh clash of the titans yeah that was
like so you can see the similarity
yeah i think they cause because he would
reuse uh some things obviously
but you know so you know all the all the
stop-motion animation looked really cool
but the matte shots were just like
really
were really not that good and like i
said even the matte shots and the
miniatures and stuff like that from the
50s one
looked better than the one from the 70s
which was kind of a bummer but like i
said it seemed like they kind of rushed
this one into production a little bit
yeah and you can kind of tell it's still
a good movie but it's not as fun as the
other two
you know what i mean it's not it doesn't
have the same like epic
yeah it doesn't feel as epic it doesn't
feel as well it's put together as well
it feels like it's kind of thrown
together
that's just that's just the impression
yeah that i got
that it was just hey let's knock this
out real quick that's what it felt like
but people are saying that they cost
more money to do that i think it was the
most expensive one yeah
it didn't feel expensive though no
second one does yeah golden boy just
send bad people i
i liked too that it's like i liked the
guy that played
um uh what the melanthius
and i was kind of like the whole time i
was like oh man i know that guy
he was the guy that was in the omen pla
that played the priest that got impaled
and i guess he was a doctor who as well
okay like he was one of the doctor who's
i guess he's maybe not i don't know i
haven't seen all the iterations of
doctor who so i didn't even know that he
was dying i just recognized him from the
omen
but it wasn't a bad movie but if i'd
only you know if i could only see one
i would see the golden voyages in bed
that's the one i would choose
i don't know i kind of like the first
one the best really
yeah i like the second one i don't know
why i
okay i like john philip law as sinbad
from golden voyage i think he
like is the best and bad of all three of
them because the
the dude that played sinbad in the 50s
one was a little bland
yeah um but overall i think i liked the
first one the best just because i
i don't know i it's to me it seemed like
the most fun the most colorful
um you know i liked the little tiny
woman and i like her like helping
everybody out and so i liked that about
it
but i don't know the golden voyage is so
awesome too because it had [ __ ]
uh you know had [ __ ] tom baker
playing a bad guy and he was [ __ ]
great in it
i liked i liked uh golden voyage better
had tom baker is the bad guy
better monsters carolyn caroline monroe
in there
and it was just it was just it was it
had a lot of sex appeal
that movie that the second one the third
one tried to
um it wasn't it it wasn't as effective
though
you know like i said you could tell
there wasn't a lot of chemistry there
yeah i think that was one of the things
they even talked about that like while
they were making the movie
in in in the golden voyager sinbad you
could tell that whoever's
the guy who was playing uh sinbad liked
caroline
monroe yeah you could tell that he was
like you know she was cute
you know yeah and here's something else
you guys didn't know this i i confirmed
this today
there's a music video by um uh
adam ant goody two shoes that's caroline
monroe when they're dressed as the down
yeah i didn't even realize i didn't
recognize her
yeah it's caroline monroe in there
dressed as the secretary of the big
round glasses
and now she did a little interview i
read it she said she was a fan
and she loved being in that video said
it was great said
said that she said there was a chemistry
between him and her but she was uh and
she was uh engaged at the time so
nothing went down so she said but she
said she
adam matt in it in his heyday he was
quite cool with that [ __ ] crazy
today
he's crazy yeah he's got he's got he's
got a little mental problems
he was foxy back then though yeah he
didn't age that well
didn't keep up he didn't keep up with
himself and uh
his act didn't evolve the right way you
know
he could uh he it could have been a lot
more modernized and
stayed with a similar motif and
something a little more age-appropriate
for him and
he's evidently crazy like he's really
crazy
yeah that's a shame i haven't been in a
while he's got some kind of
i don't know he says he has mental
health problems i don't know what it is
manga says we should check out jack the
giant killer
i've been actually wanting to watch that
it's a there's a rifftrax version of it
on uh toby and they have so many like
riff tracks on there that i'm trying to
get i'm trying to work my way through
all of them
but so i'll eventually get to jack the
giant yeah talking about adam and some
of those
cool movies and stuff that he was in
yeah he wasn't some good one yeah good
um he had some good videos oh he's
bipolar assistant bipolar is over yeah
okay
yeah i've seen him videos of him just
hanging out with people
you know what i mean just from social
media yeah
and yeah he he does not look very
comfortable with himself he looks crazy
he looks crazy he looks like he looks
like he
like he's feeling ridiculous you know
what i mean
i know that feeling yeah he's dressed up
in adam
outfits he's he's he's a little too old
to be dressed that way
and you could tell he's uncomfortable
looking like that i just
just go just go look look at look at him
he's [ __ ] crazy
got the damn napoleon hat on sideways
and just
like it's like headlights you know what
i mean
like you take a picture of me yeah just
oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ]
i still remember and this is going back
a couple of years probably like five or
six years ago
and we went to a halloween party at eye
bar independent bar
uh and one of the best halloween
costumes i saw there was a girl that
dressed up like
goodie two shoes era adam ant like she
had the military coders she looked
great [ __ ] yeah i mean it was just a
really really good costume
go check out that video guys [ __ ]
goodie two shoes and go look at caroline
she looks [ __ ] cool it's hard to
believe she's like 83 now or 82.
yeah crazy that's what it says yeah
mango said a few years back
uh adam ant went nuts with a starter
pistol and a pub in london
all right nice he's good he's going with
this one of those crazy kind of
he's going into like phone throwing mode
like
with russell crowe is it's an accepted
fact that sometimes you gotta [ __ ]
throw a phone
if i show up to the hotel you know what
i mean there's a good chance that i i
might throw a phone
what'd you say yeah [ __ ] phone
[Laughter]
the possibility is not zero that's not
zero
and when you if if you were russell
crowe you wouldn't throw a phone
i'd suck
excuse me it's time for me to throw
so i'll be back in a minute i've got
something to take care of
run into an assistant what's up what's
up mr crow how you doing you throwing in
the phones
how's the phone i got a phone can you
throw it for me
oh my god i wonder if anybody did that
afterwards like after that kind of went
and that's like years ago i don't know
why i remember it so much i'd get my old
dial phone
yeah you're like bringing my phone and
you're like can you throw this you throw
this for me i'm gonna
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what
yeah i've seen a video [ __ ] dancing
trying to beat a dude's ass for [ __ ]
with him
he kept [ __ ] the guy can't [ __ ]
tease him at the club you know trying to
get him to do danzig like [ __ ] things
you know what i mean
he goes come here come here [ __ ] come
here if i can chase him like that you
didn't see that one
i haven't seen that one i saw the one
where that dude clocked him but it's
like i haven't seen them yeah there's
another one
some douchebag kept trying to get him to
do something crazy on camera just kept
[ __ ] with him
you know what i mean do some danzig like
activity
yeah he did come here come here come
here you [ __ ] come here
he's like well that's a dancing like
activity yeah yeah yeah
you know they took my face and super to
post it on dancing
yeah he sent me that facebook i was like
that's unsettling yeah it does
yeah oh my god [ __ ]
soap is telling me that danzig should be
a regular guest on the show and that i
should get a black wig
you should or we can get a danzig
bobblehead i'm sure somebody makes one
and then you could do i mean him and btk
could have uh
little uh conversations it can't be old
dancing though
it's got to be young dancing well yeah
nobody wants a bobble head of old
dancing
everybody wants to like dance like in
his prime dance prime dancing
yeah yeah poor dancing
i'm sure isn't there there's got to be
like a vinyl pop of him i would think
there's one of everybody else [ __ ]
there's probably one of me somewhere
well they make whatever but it's like
seriously i was in a comic shop
um not too long ago like in a mall or
something that's right she's 72. yeah i
was thinking 82 yeah she's 72. that's
right
and i could not believe all of the
obscure ass
pop figures that they had i think my
favorite one was they had one
of bugs bunny from that opera parody
that they did
what's opera doc you know what i mean
where's where uh he had the
braids and the helmet yeah they had the
bug's money from that and i was like i
wanted it really bad but i didn't get it
she's 72. she doesn't look that bad for
72 though but
she's nowhere near [ __ ] like
cassandra peterson
we saw cassandra peterson in person and
she was
she was late 60s maybe 70s then wouldn't
she
yeah she was gorgeous yeah she doesn't
really look that much different she's
gorgeous yeah looks just like her i mean
she's easily recognizable
you know like that's cassandra fetus
yeah yeah and it's not just the boobs
either
or the hair like you can still recognize
her face yeah like she looks pretty much
the same yeah in good shape
the same thing with oh what's her name
the uh the girl from that we saw in
um uh the one from from beyond
barbara crampton barbara krampus barbara
crampton looks
fantastic yeah oh my god pokey what the
hell
climate thing well barbara crampton was
just in within one of the new creep
shows
yeah and she just she looks almost
exactly the same as she did back then
she looks like she has hardly aged
yeah they got her kind of dressed up
like she's a little bit older
but she can also i've seen interviews
with her where she's dressed
just you know just made up and and she
looks like a great she looks just like
she did
well i'm not i follow her in instagram
so i so she posts photos all the time
when she's
out and about doing whatever and she
looks almost exactly the same as she did
in the 80s
yeah people aren't aging the same way
that they used to especially if they
not abusing themselves and have money to
keep up with it
yeah because you do that that that's
that does help
i look at dancing i know what's going on
look i mean dancing i'm gonna go
i'm gonna have danza gone as a guest one
of these days
you've been oh [ __ ] you girl
me and dan's are probably about the same
height all right
five six five seven he's probably around
that that height
just by looking at him and i've seen him
in person he seemed about my size
he went on a cycle say when he came off
cycle that [ __ ] him up
that's how he got kind of bluffed out
like that so quickly he doesn't have
time to work out all the time but he was
he was he went on some [ __ ]
and coming off of that if you don't know
how to come off that stuff the right way
you'll get real big around the waist
it'll [ __ ] distort your face and
everything that's just
that's just what it looks like to me and
his teeth
look like looks like he's he he's
involved in some drugs you know what i
mean
he's got a meth mouth guessing slightly
you know that it's really bad
i never looked inside his mouth his
teeth are very yellowish and which
looks like damaged damaged um
enamel on his teeth i mean it could be
just smoking but
his voice is so good i wouldn't think
that he would be smoking cigarettes
but maybe he does i don't know just very
yellow yeah you think smoking would [ __ ]
up your voice afterwards
i mean it does [ __ ] up your hand and he
can still sing so i'm still singing so
some guys you know like robert plant
[ __ ] used to smoked a couple packs a
day and he's
singing that [ __ ] doing that whole
[ __ ] led zeppelin
tours and [ __ ] you know so just some
dudes if they're young enough can
can do it but you're not supposed to be
smoking that's right [ __ ] your voice up
it'll [ __ ] your voice up well it [ __ ]
up your [ __ ] lungs you know
yeah your lungs and it [ __ ] up your
ability to hold a note for a long period
of time you know
but uh maybe he was doing it i don't
know just he just
he looks like he's lived kind of a rough
life
yeah yeah and um i think he just stayed
up in that old house of
l.a little [ __ ] junky looking house
he lived in true
yeah he sold it he didn't live there
anymore well
yeah oh thank you mango love these
classic sinbad reviews and some respect
their forgotten classics
i do kind of feel like that and i was
going to say too i forgot to mention
this but i think that
uh another thing that sort of worked
against sinbad in the eye of the tiger
even though it did make its money back
and it made like decent
uh box office was that this came out in
1977 guess what else came out in 1977
star wars um so star wars had come out
just a couple of months before this
and next to star wars something like
this is maybe not gonna look so
fantastic well especially because the uh
effects in star wars
star wars were so good like all the mats
and miniatures and stuff and the
so i think that you know the fact that
the mats and miniatures didn't look as
good in this one
maybe kind of suffered by comparison
also
so i think i think they were gonna make
like some more too i think
after the sci-fi boom hit they were
gonna make like sinbad goes to mars and
some [ __ ] like that
but they never did it danny says i heard
denzel wear his lips
in his shoes like mickey from science
but he probably does
i don't know i mean he should just like
own
his not he's not like a [ __ ] he's not
a little person he's just like a writer
yeah he's
just sure but that doesn't that doesn't
mean anything there's lots of short guys
that are on stage making a [ __ ] ton of
money
nobody was as small as [ __ ] um uh
ronnie james dio
that dude was [ __ ] tiny but you
wouldn't know about listening to him
though this [ __ ] sounded like an
eight-foot giant
and everybody loved ronnie yes everybody
loved ronnie james dio they said he was
one of the nicest guys ever
no ego but the mother [ __ ] could
sing cancer got him though
yeah danzig made a mistake of [ __ ]
running his mouth
just to the wrong people when he was
young in a time that was changing and
he got pigeonholed and [ __ ] stuck with
him and they
drove him over it you know what i mean
if i could it's hard to be
a satanist in a world full of atheists
[Laughter]
that was his stick and he was he kind of
had a negative
attitude and that's not really who he
was i mean if you
go back and look at you know what was
what was going on in the misfits and
photographs of who he was at that time
he was a little cutie boy really what he
was a little punk rock cutie boy a
little bitty guy
uh he wasn't muscular or anything but he
was he was attractive and
girls liked him and um it's rumored he
was
you know messing around with vampira
when he was a teenager which that's
that might be plausible i know that she
used to show up at some of his shows
yeah dressed up in her vampire outfit
well they wrote that song she would have
been in her 50s i think at that time
40s or 50s you know which i guess that's
not big you know she was about yeah and
he was you know
16 17. and um
but he just uh he did he he he
tried to transform he was transformed
himself into a [ __ ] badass he tried
to do it
just on the back of being a singer you
know and
working out for a little bit it's and
reading stuff you know i mean it's
you say the wrong things in front of the
press they're gonna [ __ ] with you that's
what happened to him
well i think honestly his issue is that
he just takes himself too seriously yeah
he doesn't have a sense of humor about
himself he has like a really inflated
sense of his own
importance and security always yeah well
that's always like really dangerous when
you have somebody that
really that's so insecure that they just
they have to
one pretend like they're smarter and
more badass than everybody else
and they can't laugh at themselves they
can't take a joke they can't you know
what i mean and so
and obviously people that can't take a
joke or can't laugh at themselves people
are going to go out of their way to like
[ __ ] with you
because it's much funnier yeah because
you can't take it
and who he really is if you ask me he
was a he was really a guy
kind of more like daddy filth if you
know who danny phillip is
yeah you know it's just with the danny
phil
was danny filth really was just the the
black metal [ __ ] um
um uh robert smith really sure
[Laughter]
a little bitty robert smith but little
little bitty black metal robert smith
it's a little paper yeah [ __ ] danny
filth you know you see
you hear his voice and [ __ ] see
photographs of him you know back
back when we all listened to cds and
didn't know who was who
he sounded like a [ __ ] just evil
demon you know probably like a big
intimidating guy no a little bitty guy
yeah a little bit of guy you know who
and with a with a personality very
similar to
in a way kind of like you know robert
smith
yeah yep all right so let's go ahead and
cut it short
yeah i think we're at 46 minutes yeah so
yeah
all three of these sinbad movies if you
wanted some nostalgia you want to watch
them again they're all on amazon prime
yeah
and uh like i said i'm not sure about
this country but i'm see i've seen some
british reviewers that had like a really
nice
three blu-ray box set i don't know if
they sell that over here
i didn't see it on our amazon but i saw
a bunch of british reviewers had it
um but yeah so check them out if you
like your old school fantasy and
ray harryhausen all that we should uh
it's making me want to watch clash of
the titans again yeah we can see that
we'll have we'll do clash of the titans
next week yeah i don't want to see
atlanta time for god again also
and then people at time forgotten yeah i
think tomorrow we'll probably do a food
show because
tonight we have to go to memento mori
they're doing a
they're doing a what do you call it
masquerade ball tonight so we're not
gonna have time to watch a movie tonight
so we'll probably just do a food show
tomorrow
at 3 p.m eastern standard time as usual
so thanks everybody for dropping by
and we will see you guys tomorrow bye